And the correct answer is: of course they will eventually matter.
So No is the correct answer, and let me show this to you.
Again, assume our 4 landmarks
and consider our robot facing to the right, to this direction.
We get a certain set of distances
that is invariant to the orientation.
But now this robot moves, and we get a new set of distances.
And now orientation matters.
If we assume a different initial orientation,
like this one over here--
and that robot moves--
its measurements will be very, very different.
So orientation does matter in the second step of particle filtering
because the prediction is so different for different orientations.
Let's go and program this.